Hi,
this is Morgan from the linguistics
channel and you've probably noticed that I
haven't uploaded a video in a while.
Um,
I've been pretty busy and I haven't
made the time to keep this channel live.
However,
I've noticed great growth in the channel.
I have over 3000 subscribers now,
which is mind blowing. I can't,
I can't even believe that. Um,
I'm, I'm really grateful for, for,
for all the comments that you guys
have been leaving on my video. Many of,
many of you want me to come back,
you want me to make more videos,
which is exactly what I'm planning
to do in the coming months. Um,
so let me know what types of
videos you would like to see. Um,
I noticed that a large
base of my subscribers are
actually from a non English
speaking countries so
that many of you are, are,
are trying to learn English
as a second language. Um,
let me know if you'd like to see more
videos related to learning English as a
second language. Um, I think that would
be, that would be a fun project. Um,
I'm also thinking about doing some more.
Basically with sticks videos as well as
etymology videos like I did in the past.
Um,
let me know in the comments below what
types of videos you'd like to see on this
channel. Because you're a subscriber, you
subscribe to this channel for a reason,
and I want to start producing
content, um, that, that,
that you guys will enjoy. Um, thank you
so much for the support. Until next time,
have a great day.
I would also just like to mention
that I speak Spanish very fluently.
I speak some French and I can
sometimes get by in Portuguese.
So if you want to leave your comments
in any of those languages [inaudible] en
espanol or foresee, you know, Paul,
so 10 tag his phone,
Dave in pour through gates
standing Obrigado Merci beaucoup.